I just got this alert on my phone I have
this new app called citizen where you
put in your zip code and it tells you
any kind of like crime or events that
are happening in or around your
neighborhood I just got a Manhattan
Alert at least three people were injured
after multiple manhole explosions what
what breaking news where why did um it
says Flatiron District who knows the
other day it was like man with blowtorch
at 9th and 11th and I'm like okay I
guess I'll avoid that I actually thought
it was weird that you would have that I
was just like how are you not getting
every like we have the craziest people
it's fun and this app is really fun
especially you live in a crazy town yeah
I just I mean is gonna happen like right
next to you and you're gonna be like I
don't know I guess you'll be aware the
guy with the blowtorch is gonna be like
10 feet away from you I don't know about
it I should just not know about it I
don't know you're gonna be reading the
app while he's burning you
[Music]
dr. Phil is walking into studio as we
speak yes right here dr. Phil how you
doing good how are you I'm so good
you've been on the show before we we got
you in here before and I told you how
much you mean to me a couple of your
phrases have changed my life I refer to
them often how's that working for you
that's one of my faves
I mean you can't beat it how's that
working for you did you come up with
that on your own
I mean it's so good it's just it's you
can't not answer that with like wow it's
not working out good at all and I got to
change my life you know it's all about
asking the right questions right yeah we
have to ask ourselves the right
questions I I really got into all of
this I started thinking back and I
really got into all of this when I was
12 because when I was 12 I really got
focused on why people do what they do
and don't do what they don't do I've
been obsessed with that one concept
since I was 12 years old right and since
then that's been that's been a driving
force in what I do yeah
well I was on a football team in
Oklahoma City and we had a game rainout
and so on the weekend and so on Monday
the Salvation Army called and said we
have a team we kind of put together
could we come over and scrimmage you
guys and our coach said yeah sure and we
had all the best equipment I mean dust
shiny helmets a black with silver
stripes down this and they showed up in
two pickups and it looked like the most
ragtag team you've ever seen the guy
lined up across from me had on blue
jeans for football pants rolled up to
the knee so they look like hitting
loafers for football shoes a button-up
shirt
with masking tape number four on it and
we're cycling we're snickering like why
doesn't he put it on with magic marker
well we're so dumb we don't know that's
you didn't put it on magic marker
because that's his shirt oh yeah where
that's a school oh yeah so we have all
of this stuff and here's his ragtag kids
with nothing so we don't kick off
because just a scrimmage they snapped
the ball that kid hit me so hard it
still hurts when he they beat us like
they were clapping for a barn dance I
mean it was like 50 to nothing and I'm
thinking I got in the car as my dad to
go home and I said what happened
and he said you just got your ass handed
to you on a platter that's what I said I
was looking for a little more in-depth
answer than that he said they're just
hungry they want it and at that point I
was envious of those kids I was envious
to those Salvation Army kids I like I
want what they have and I started
focusing why people do what they do and
don't do what they don't do
why are those kids so hungry why do they
want it so bad because if they can do so
much for so little how much should I be
able to do with so much what makes them
tick and I started reading and I just
became fascinated with you know how did
you make that drive for yourself if you
did have everything how did you create
that kind of well you know for me I
started figuring out that you really are
self determined you don't I I started
really figuring out that you create your
own experience you you you create your
own drive you don't wait for somebody
else to do it for you yeah and I've been
very self-reliant from a very young age
so that became the ticket for me of
being self-reliant and that doesn't mean
I'm a lone wolf I surround myself with
people that
want me to succeed and are competent and
help and all that but that's part of
creating your own environment you people
around you that are really good at what
they do we were unpacking some absurd
behavior that we notice just living in
New York City on the train and such and
I'd love for you to shed some light on
why someone might listen to their phone
at full volume when they have headphones
on a crowded train and and subject
everyone to whatever video they're
watching what what kind of person does
that and why do they do that well
there's two answers different answers
that one it's they're just very
narcissistic and selfish but if they're
like watching the video the people that
do it on their phone they want you to
know how important they are so they're
talking not to the person on the phone
they're talking to you they're not
talking to this guy they're talking to
you and you and you and you and this is
exhibitionism for them so they're
putting on a show for everybody there
and they love an audience and they've
got a captive win on that train and
they're gonna use it they are performing
and then you cannot escape it now are
you at the type of person that will call
that kind of behavior out in public or
do you think that it's more wise to just
let them be no I don't call it out in
public I label it yeah and with some
masking tape if somebody asked me about
it at the time I'll tell them right in
front of the person but I don't say
anything the person I just move on I'm
you know it's like if I go to a dinner
or a party or something and somebody
says oh so it's getting a divorce or you
think about this or anything about that
I'm the last one to weigh in just
somebody to come to me and say what do
you think is you don't want to know what
I think y'all just keep talking I'm just
going to eat my salad I'm the last one
to give it my
um really just in a public setting but
wouldn't someone's asked I mean you're
the best at giving advice I mean another
one of yours dr. Phil isms that I use
quite often is when someone says I don't
know you say well if you did know what
would you say I think that's so
brilliant because you do have an answer
somewhere of course yeah
I mean that's just a deflection yes
somebody I don't know yeah you do you do
you're just pretending not to know yeah
it's it is so frustrating though dealing
with certain behaviors and you go why do
you do that do you have do you find that
the people you encounter on your show
and and definitely the people you're
talking to you in your new podcast which
I want to talk about he has a new dr.
Bell has a new true crime podcast called
analysis of murder by dr. Phil season
one is out now which features the first
exclusive interview with gypsy Rhodes
Rose Blanche Blanche Sharda Blanchard
Blanchard until her mother added an E so
it would have a little panache to it and
so it became bland charred
hilarious miss Blanchard until she added
the e well and this is the the story
that is the show the act on Hulu if you
watch that is based upon all this but
you meet a lot of these people that you
could just want a big you're just so
frustrated with why are you acting this
way
um empathy is a big part of your job
I would assume and can you talk to us a
little bit about that because I feel
like a lot of people don't even know
what it is I know I found out late in
life what it is people have sympathy but
what's the difference between empathy
and sympathy well there's a big
difference you know sympathy is really
feeling compassion for or feeling sorry
for or even having pity for empathy is
the ability to put yourself in their
position stand in their shoes and
vicariously experience what they're
likely experiencing in a situation and
you can tell whether somebody really has
that ability or not
based on a couple of litmus tests if you
want to know what they are love it
like let's say somebody comes to work
and they show up late you say you're
late you're never late you know why are
you late then they say well just I was
getting ready to leave my dog ran into
the street and was run over and killed
now somebody that doesn't have empathy
holding a nice coffee when they say this
[Laughter]
somebody without empathy will say oh
really what kind of dog oh wow
somebody with empathy will say oh my
gosh you must feel terrible about that
sit down I'm so sorry yeah one reflects
content the other reflects feeling so
people that don't have empathy can
reflect content because they don't
understand feelings people that have
empathy will reflect feelings because
they understand it they can relate to
what that person must be feeling because
they say if somebody killed my dog I
would feel terrible so you must feel
terrible they can relate to it that's
empathy they can they can put themselves
that person's situation and experience
accurately what that person is likely to
be experiencing but what if I've never
had a dog what if I don't would never
even had a pet how do I experience you
know people that have experienced loss
you've lost something you've had
something about you taken from you
you've had something that's yeah that's
a good point
okay so I want to unpack okay so you
just you're in the middle of saying
something oh there's I said I lost my
phone that's what they're laughing at I
compared the two you know what here's
what I was thinking about was we all saw
this report about this woman who dumped
all these puppies at Coachella did you
see that no oh you didn't
puppies inside its 7 puppies in a sack
this woman they went to they later found
her but they went to her home and she
had like 38 dogs at her home she's one
of these pet hoarders you know and and
she put they have the footage of her
putting the dogs in the dumpster in a
sack and doing it so nonchalantly that
you're kind of like oh she's done this
before probably and just acting without
any like care for these dogs lives the
dogs got found they're fine
I felt I for the first time ever instead
of feeling just so angry at that woman
which obviously it was I was like that
poor woman what has she been through to
make it so easy for her to dispose of
puppies lives like that do you find
yourself arriving at those kind of is
that growth for me as a human that I'm
able to see even empathize with
murderers and people who've done
horrible things cuz I go even the
Michael Jackson documentary I'm like
what what happened to Michael Jackson to
make him do this like it's and where
does that end I can go back millions of
years like what pain brought about you
know it depends it just depends on where
you focus at the time you can also
relate to the puppies yeah you can also
relate to the victims of Michael Jackson
right so it doesn't mean that you don't
have compassion for the perpetrator as
well as the victim because you know this
has to be a tortured soul yes to have
done that so you you can't understand
that I mean I've been people have
criticized me at times for saying that
we shouldn't necessarily punish bullies
we need to treat them because bullies
come from homes where bullies raise kids
bullies have been bullied and you got to
ask yourself what is it that makes these
kids so angry that they're venting this
all the time and if you want to stop it
you really have to fix the bullies not
just punish them because all you're
gonna do is make them more angry so
bullies need help just like the victims
of the bullies
and that's not a popular sentiment but
if you want to fix it it's true but
isn't the whole root of the criminal
justice system is that we're just we're
punishing people that come from homes
where maybe they stole because there is
no food to have and they have no other
way of making a living or you know what
I mean like there's there's definitely
evil people out there but I think
there's a bigger majority of people that
did something for reasons whether they
know it consciously or unconsciously
well the whole system is based on
deterrent that if we punish these people
it will deter others from doing it so
you're basically writing these people
off like you know we're we're not gonna
worry about these people by punishing
these 10,000 will stop a hundred
thousand from doing the same behavior it
just doesn't work it doesn't work yeah I
mean you go house warehouse people in a
cage and you don't do anything to
rehabilitate them you don't do anything
to teach them to make a better choice
and then you put them right back in the
situation that they came from and wonder
why there's 85 percent recidivism rate
it doesn't work why doesn't it work why
doesn't why doesn't seeing someone in
jail and thinking I could go to jail
deter people from going cuz they just
can't see that for themselves they just
don't think it'll happen to them because
you're always the exception right the
guy's dumb that guy's dumb there no
catch me right they'll never catch me he
was an idiot I'm not we do just so many
things to trick ourselves into doing
what we really want to do I mean like
we'll find an excuse to do it yeah we'll
justify it and they're different I'm
different you know it's not the same
you're not the exception yeah so really
fill in the blanks is dr. Phil's other
podcast you have a new true crime
podcast called analysis of murder by dr.
Phil and then fill in the blanks is your
podcast you have your show of course are
your would keep adding things I've you I
always look at you and think of that
that man is so busy how do you what do
you do to relax
I come by here and talk to you this is
work for you dr. Phil you're working
right now you're on a press tour I mean
I can't even believe you're here I feel
honored that you've given me a moment of
your time
no but I enjoy sitting and talking to
you yeah you do
can't you tell yeah I can't tell I mean
like you you like you wouldn't be doing
this if you didn't like it I feel like
you do you do things you don't like
anymore no that's great you get to that
point in your career I mean like don't
do your when you're coming up you just
say yes everything you're doing things
you don't really want to do to propel
yourself when do you go I'm not gonna do
anything I don't want to do anymore I've
been there a couple of times you know I
was in the trial science before you know
courtroom Sciences that's what whoops
that's what one of my other shows is
based on bull she's on Monday nights at
ten o'clock that's another show
yeah that's based on my life before dr.
Phil I was in that business trial
sciences which is you know consulting
with litigation crime civil whatever and
I certainly got to that point in that
business where I just simply didn't take
cases I didn't want to do I probably
took 1 out of 10 cases that was
presented we started out going after
business and very soon we were fielding
business took the ones that we wanted
not too much we didn't and you know at
this point you know some of it I think
is age too you get to the point where
it's like you know life's too short I'm
too old for this yeah I'll do what
I want to do and not what I don't but I
love what I do so let me ask dr. Phil
this you get a coffee and it tastes bet
you spend 5 bucks on a coffee and it's
not made the way you wanted it to be
made you take your coffee specifically
do you do you have specific coffee
orders are you just like whatever um
drink coffee okay well let's say you're
getting us something that you
you get it you can get there so and it's
not up to snuff and the coffee shop is
busy and do you go up and ask them to
get it right or do you just go I'm just
not gonna drink it and throw it away and
take the loss no I can get it right and
why is that why do you what do you think
people should cuz I want it cuz you want
it yeah I mean if I didn't I wouldn't
have aren't you being annoying and don't
they make minimum wage and aren't you
making their lives harder or all these
things we tell ourselves when we when
you get the wrong food order and you go
oh they put cheese in my cell and I
don't want cheese and I didn't ask for
it but I just don't want to be annoying
so I'll just let it sit here and she
comes back and she goes did you not like
this it's like mom I just am not hungry
anymore and we just lie to them even
though they got it wrong no I can be
very charming yes you can do this in a
charming way yeah you really can you can
fire people in a charming way really
yeah oh my god will you fire Andrew
right now my attitude is I try to I try
to make sure that people feel better
about themselves after interacting with
me than they did before and it doesn't
matter whether it's a waiter or a
checkout clerk at the grocery store or
whoever and that's a pretty good rule
actually if you can if you can engage
people in a way that they feel better
about themselves after interacting with
you than they did before that's gonna
work for you pretty well in your life
that is a good rule to take out that
I'll remember so you know people if
you're if you're in a restaurant and
they're taking forever for them to come
take care of you they can walk up and
you can say well it's about time
first off I'm not doing that somebody's
going to take my food behind closed
doors
but you know instead if they woke up and
you just say boy they should give you
skates tonight you are really running
around here aren't you
it's like oh my God thank you for saying
that we had two people not show up
tonight yes and you say well I can tell
but you know it's okay but we'll tell
you what we need but we'll be all right
don't worry about us you're gonna get
the best service there and they're gonna
appreciate you and it just takes so
little effort to make somebody feel
better about themselves and to
appreciate you know you doing there yeah
I've noticed that the most with like um
when you call like customer service
because it's always your it's always a
complaint you're not calling customer
service because you're having something
great happen but what I've noticed is
they didn't make the rules so I've
always gone in and been like hey I don't
want to shoot the messenger this is what
happened on my Delta flight yes I know
it's not your fault but I kind of need
to be compensated I missed two flights
because of it because of work I didn't
you know what I mean and you start to
lay it out but you kind of let them know
like I know none of this is your fault
you answer phones yeah make the rules
but you have to like and you start to
take them kind of on a journey and I
don't know why I'm able to do that much
better when it's faceless I'm able to
kind of stick up for myself yeah but
when I see a barista is like dead inside
and tired and doesn't want to be there
and all I think is I know this Terry's
gonna hurt my stomach yes I'm just gonna
go I mean and I do I
every time I'm just like I can see it's
almost like empathizing too much because
I see her I was her and I go why am i I
have five dollars to go who's gonna go
there are two really important things
though that we don't do enough in this
country and one is eye contact people
don't look each other in the eye enough
and use their name makes a big big
difference okay because you disrespected
me of their faceless but if you look him
in the eye and call him by name
makes a huge difference what's my name
Nicky what's my name
you're not
I just got I feel without change because
he looked me in the eye and said my name
so I walk in I'm all high as
and I never get high and I think it's a
party yeah a lot of people packed into
your dorm Wow
suddenly my dorm room it's part of the
place to be yeah it's the hottest
biggest girls every high I know her from
the faith you know you would look
through the book yes oh my god
Shelley's here Stacey everyone I circled
these girls I'm hi I'm like party I
should have my dream it's the first
month of college you're Van Wilder
you're back Wow Wow and I got a pump
ready to go you pump before class
it's palm I could put it 69 times
[Music]
walk in I see my roommate reached for
the drawer I'm like that's not your side
Seth
I thought your side of the room what are
you doing Seth go to your side oh no
that's the drawer that I keep my penis
pump it that's you're putting it all
together he reaches and he pulls the
pump like this he's swinging it like
like like David fought Goliath through
the slingshot Karolina raise up take
your penis pump and spin it round your
head kind of like a helicopter like a
lemon party yeah
and he goes what the is this what
is this yelling what is this and it gets
real quiet everyone looks at me is
everyone laughing and hooting and
hollering at this point no one yet
everyone's quiet quiet and they go
everyone's looking at me because no one
really knows what it is like don't know
like no people have an idea of what is
cylindrical and there's something
there's there's a way that maybe someone
could think a penis could be involved in
this but yeah it is inconclusive at this
point conclusive I look at everyone I
just go hey that's my that's my penis
palm and that's when the laughter
remember when Billy Madison when the
clown falls and breaks his head that's
where I had the scene was like the
laughter on every hot girls face it was
so intense the pointing I mean it was
like everyone was just yelling that's
what I'm hearing
yeah wait they are not saying they're
not yeah they're not jamming that but in
my head that's what I'm hearing his tiny
dick see I want to just stop you right
there if I were a girl and I saw a guy
at a penis pump I would just think that
he probably has a big dick because he's
been pumping like I wouldn't be like oh
yes where were you then but that's what
everyone was thinking in that room I
guarantee you they weren't like oh he
has a small I don't know that's not
where I would have gone well that's
where I went boy yeah then I was so
stoned that I threw the pump and it
broke on the ground i room
I need it was 45 40 bucks down the drain
did it haunt you for a while yeah I
didn't leave my dorm room
I'm not kidding for three weeks I would
look out the window and Billy what a
regular Dick's up to with no pumps and
then I'd be like and then I'd walk down
the quad like when I finally like left
I'm doing looking around like I would
like hide under trees like if I saw a
girl that was in the room that had been
in the room and seen your palm
yeah and then I till the end of that
year to a girl that wasn't in the room
yeah have you ever pumped again no no
that was fun to be quiet like that
I haven't I would pump now you would top
oh no problem with the pump it was a
young thing where it was a big thing but
now I would I would have sex with a
pocket but any like
the one that comes with a but I would I
would do all of that I would go in a
store and and I'll take this whole wall
take the whole wall of pumps and I'm
pumping for an all yeah because I'm
secure now and I think I wish that brain
was in that kid because I could have
talked to a child at home that might be
interested in purchasing a pump and and
let them know yeah what what have you
learned from well what's changed for you
from that freshman year when you felt so
embarrassed to have that pump and you
stayed inside for three weeks because
people knew you had a penis pump how
have you gotten to this point where you
would pump in front of anyone no in fact
he goes in pumps in front of freshman at
college every year in honor of this
event that happened to him to celebrate
it and to honor it he'll go pump in
front of him and Hertz school an entire
class right yes I do that I do that I
this is what happens when you get older
you realize certain things are important
okay and then when you end up getting
defeated over and over again horrible
things happen to you you start putting
things in perspective perspective is
very important at that time when I was
18 the worst
that ever happened to me well I got
stabbed but other than that was the
penis pump so I didn't have other thing
and my parents divorced that was sad and
my grandpa died and and we killed a
snake once well that died actually a
couple years ago but the pump was bad
and I didn't have perspective them but
now that my life is a shambles I was a
dog walker I'm in debt I have q-tips
used in my pocket sometimes I don't
clean my sheets I don't have all my
teeth what else humans mispronounce
things I mispronounce words you have a
speech impediment I've speech
impediments you you often will have your
stomach hanging out stomach will hang
out sometime for that and then I won't
even know how ill 39 year old man with
his stomach so my point is is that now a
pump isn't that big of a deal when so
turn your life into shambles get into
some trouble out there get anal fissures
and then the pump won't be so bad bro
you just saw clip from you up with Nikki
Glaser check here every Tuesday for a
new clip from my radio show you up with
Nikki Glaser from our radio show with
you up with Andrew and Nicky never
Andrew Collins radio show who happens
that Nikki on some done okay we all know
that's not true